the most important skill of a developer
is not programming in itself but
actually how to use google properly a
lot of answers are already there on the
internet a lot of algorithms are written
a lot of libraries are present a lot of
things have already been done your job
as a programmer
mostly is never to come up with
something innovative or something
extremely brand new but your job is to
glue together a bunch of systems which
are not working together initially but
your job is to just make sure that these
systems work together you can find these
existing system maintained well
maintained systems through google and
you can find how to link them together
with google as well but most people i
don't know why shy away from google i'm
the kind of person who will google a
topic and then open 10 the top 10 links
in 10 different tabs and then take the
intersection of everyone why because
this helps me to remove the bias from
all the other people which have written
a particular piece of content